[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
العمليات الفلاحيه بجمع البذره من المواقع
اللي فيها الاشجار نحن بنثق فيها كباحثين
عاليه الانتاج وبنجي نزرع هذه البزره دي
في المشاكل ثم بعد ذلك ننقل هذه البشره
البذره الى المواقع في الحق خصوصا انه في
محطه بحوث الابيض عندنا غابه
حوالي
7500 فدان كلها مزروعه بالخشاب في بعض
المناطق صح الهجاب بقوم بصوره طبيعيه
لكن هنا عندنا في في البحوث او في محطه
البحوث الابيض في غابه معروفه ومعلومه
لكثير من الناس
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نحن الان امام شجره الهشاب واحده من
الاشجار المنتجه للصمغ العربي واللي هي
الاكيشياء السنغال
معروفه هنا في شمال كردفان والصمغ وطبعا
معروف في منطقه شمال الكردفان او كردفان
بصوره عامه بانه الصمغه الكردفاني معروفه
عالميا لانه بيتميز بمناخ مختلف تماما من
حيث التربه ودرجه الحراره والرطوبه
فانتاجوا عالي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
انتهت مرحله الطق ونحن بدينا مرحله طلقت
او اللي هو حصاد الصمغ العربي فالان ما
شاء الله نحن شايفين الصمغ يعني موجود في
الشجره بصوره واضحه جدا وهو تحديد ال45
يوم من التاريخ الطق اول لقطه عشان يكون
حجم الكعكول معقول ويسموه زي نضج يعني
بالنسبه لي ده بنسميه ونحن الكعكول يعني
فبيكون نضج وبيكون جاهز لانه للحصاد يعني
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]